I love sports and I love playing sports
I like games playing games and whenever
you know you hear about or think about
cheating I think most of us say oh you
know the knee-jerk responses that's
terrible like people shouldn't cheat
right they shouldn't break the rules but
then I got to thinking about it and
sometimes when I read the sports section
of a newspaper particularly it seems
like about three-quarters the articles
are about some version of cheating
either contractually your performance
enhancing or trying to gain some
advantage without outside the rules I
got to thinking you know maybe we
actually like it that way cheating is
just like the heightened version of
wanting to win really really badly so in
a way you kind of admire the people who
cheat to win a cheating to lose is
different and we punish no one more than
the people who like throw games cheating
to lose we really don't like but
cheating to win I think we kind of get
it we say that you know even if it's
like Alex Rodriguez who's you know I
live in New York he's probably he went
from being one of the he's still one of
the most famous athletes in the last 50
years but went from being revered for
his unbelievable talent to being one of
the most despised athletes because he
just cheated over and over again and
kept lying about and kept getting caught
a very kind of ham-handed way but even
so you kind of have to respect someone
who wants so badly to win and do better
that they're willing to give themselves
human growth hormone or die so so in
that way I kind of think that cheating
is like something that we root for a
little bit we get it we identify with it
deflategate I mean it's kind of idiotic
on one way on the other hand look how
totally obsessed we are with the fact
that the New England Patriots may have
taken I don't know a half pound or a
pound square inch of air pressure out of
the footballs we love it and so like as
a moralist you say cheating is bad we
should decry all cheating cheating in
sports is terrible but as a person if
you look at how much we love it and as
an economist you know you look at not
what people say they love but what they
actually do like not what you know if
you ask people how are you going to
spell give you a hundred dollars how are
you going to spend it oh I'm going to
give fifty dollars away then I'll use
the other thirty dollars to buy a
present for
my friend then maybe the other bit i'll
buy something for myself but then if you
watch how people then if you give people
a hundred dollars and see how they
actually spend it they don't give half
away right so we might say we hate
cheating but I think in our hearts we
kind of love it because it gives us
something else to talk about when the
games are over